joining me here on the rich eisen show
right here and now in about an hour is
when he and michael holly take the reins
how are you sir
good man uh strong take as usual on nil
and it's just like
like how far reaching is this and how
many
aspects of it have we yet to really and
by we i mean
these universities yeah get our arms
around i mean
the the the word that has always come to
mind for me
with with college athletics is control
and you know forget coaches
imposing social media or outright media
bans on players
um you're now affecting their livelihood
i mean imagine they've avoided the the
scenario of
certain states and therefore certain
schools having a recruiting advantage
you know just across the board with the
with the presence or or lack of of name
image and likeness
opportunities but now since everybody
just kind of doing it their own way
imagine players entering into maybe you
touched on this already if you have them
sorry but imagine players
entering into transfer portals just
based on
name imaging like this opportunities i
mean just
that they're they're not going to be
this is the first of all let me just say
this is the this is the bare minimum
that can be done for college athletes i
mean it's still there's still a pie that
they're not getting access to
correct which is the the the revenue pie
the television you know
pie the the the big money the billions
with the b
but the millions that they can now make
offer their name image and likeness
that's just
bare minimum long overdue the least that
they can do well
well chaos that is going to cause in
chaos in a good way i'm an agent of
chaos
right the amount of chaos that this is
going to bring forth to the
ncaa and these in these these
institutions
comfortable situation that they've been
having for decades i don't even think we
fully grasp
just how far reaching this is going to
be i agree with you michael and i have
no problem
with a player entering a transfer portal
because he thinks his name
image and likeness may be somewhere else
and it's it it's in the same way that i
asked daryl moore
years ago when he was still with the
rockets so a couple years ago
when i'm like so aren't you concerned
that a star player
in the nba is going to approach one of
your star players and say how about you
leave where you're
the the rockets and join me somewhere
else and we'll form a super team
and his answer was no like that he's not
going to see he he wouldn't want a
tampering charge to be levied against
another player for approaching one of
his other players
he said no i'm not concerned about it
because i'm going to create such an
environment
that uh my guy's never going to think of
leaving and and
that's what will have to be yeah in the
mind's eye
and part of the plan of a college
program sports corporations or brands
this is so exciting i mean you know from
a player's perspective or an athlete's
perspective but a worker
uh think about how many brands or
corporations can now just
circumvent the the university
or the athletic department where
otherwise they may have to do some kind
of a
endorsement deal with the university in
general they could just say oh no i'll
just instead of instead of doing a deal
with duke i'll just deal with zion
williamson
you know for example at the time yeah he
came in with a
incredible social media following before
he ever set foot on you know
on campus uh so yeah i
i'm i'm super excited to see where this
goes
um and there's just so many different
tentacles like the one you pointed out i
mean
on a professional level like that is a
huge advantage
for agents oh yeah to be able to now
have a body of work
to refer to so yeah okay fine we don't
we don't have it in writing
that you know you have to i have to be
your contract agent when you go to the
nfl do we need it in writing
you know if i do a good job if i do
exactly okay and your family's
comfortable with me and i'm coming here
and and and for anybody who says well
now this opens the door for nfl
uh contract advisors this is referred to
in agents to to descend upon college
campuses they're they're there already
right you know what why do you why do
you think a player on the day that
they've made their announcement that
they're turning pro
they already have their agents all lined
up you know i mean like that's the way
it goes and some players already have
like their parents or family members do
that anyway
so it's it's it's it's fascinating to me
though michael smith of
brother from another top of the hour
right here on nbc sports on peacock
it's fascinating to me uh michael part
of the conversation about name image and
likeness is
give reggie his heisman back and his
records back and
and give uh like say uh michigan
its banners back from the fab five and
you know what how i feel about the fab
five and i love
c webb and he even tweeted out you know
give me the keys the keys to the locker
with the banners
but i i kind of have a i don't have an
issue with individual
uh records being restored and i don't
have a problem with the heisman being
given back to reggie but
you know if a team actually has a player
on on to to form
their championship roster because
somebody got an impermissible benefit in
others at the time with the rules being
what they are despite how
now illegal they appear to be in an
anti-trust violation
that that's the rules then and so team
uh records shouldn't be restored or
banners
shouldn't be restored but i think c web
should maybe get some pool of money for
that number four that was in the
michigan
uh athletics department store at the
time
couldn't agree more i think you know i
think that you know that's not name
image enlightenment i think we're
talking about brought
in in a broad sense as athletes rights
what these athletes
as workers should have been and are
entitled to
and there's so many parallels across
broader society
that we could you know be here all day
you know connecting those dots
um but yeah it's almost like as if if
imagine
major league baseball saying uh you know
performance nets and drugs are legal now
you know and and somebody uh who abided
by the rules were like
wait a second you know how does somebody
who cheated now get the benefit
right whether whether whether it should
have been considered cheating at the
time is beside the point
there were plenty of people and maybe
not to the level of reggie bush
but plenty of people who could have and
maybe did but just didn't get caught
could have circumvented the rules but
didn't i if there is no the only the
only thing
is and even then if you are going on at
that slope like how many people should
we now pay out retroactively
because they were not able and i'm not
saying they should they don't deserve it
but it's like there's no way to actually
make up
for the the you know the decades
and the billions of dollars that these
employees of the ncaa were denied
because the rules were so archaic it's
really a shame
that it took this long it really is but
it's changed forever
and it's going to really be weird for
people you know of our um
you know i guess age group generation
however you want to put it i know you're
younger than i
am but you know you've grown up your
whole life thinking you know college
athletes don't get paid
and soon there will be a generation of
people who
for whom that that's the way that
that'll be like black and white
television to a generation you know
but but here's the thing man listen i'm
not that much younger than you i'm 40
i'm almost 42 how old are you
i'm 52. so you are all right all right
i appreciate the all right that's i
appreciate the half-hearted all right i
appreciate it
you know you're better shape than i am i
guarantee you you run a better 40 than i
do
okay that's a guarantee you're on a
better tonight um
but you know even and it's
certainly preceded me one of my first
term papers
in high school i remember it was the
case for collegiate
athletes to get paid so like there are
there's a lot of us
who have been living in this alternate
universe i just finished watching
episode 4
loki who have been operating in this
nexus event this alternate timeline
in which collegiate athletes are treated
the way for for what they are for who
they really are which is employees which
is professional
athletes they may not play at the
highest level
but their they're employees so this is
really just a long time coming up i
would like to think for more people than
maybe we realize there are some old
school people
you know who are gonna who are like oh
this is weird you know this is this
this compromise the integrity of the
game is there oh it's all just
about the money it's always been about
the money but that money has always been
concentrated
to the powers that be whether it's the
administrators the the coaches
the universities ncaa what have you it
is just so
it's so refreshing to see this happening
it really is it's like
i'm i'm i couldn't be more excited for
him um and i'm excited to see just
i'm looking forward to the chaos i'm
looking forward to all the different
aspects and all the different doors that
it ends up opening the domino effect
that it has
because i hadn't even thought about the
agent aspect of it until you brought it
up like and how much how much more is
going to be revealed
as time goes on how is this going to
factor into recruiting how is it going
to factor into
uh you know competitive balance or
imbalance and so on and so forth it's
just
eventually they just have to come to
grips with the fact that this is a
professional sport
whether they you know wanted to be about
the universities wanted to be an amateur
um an amateur enterprise or not it's a
professional sport
and we're getting we it's a it's a huge
step
but it's a baby step nonetheless
relatively speaking michael smith here
on the rich eisen show uh before i let
you go
um the the uh i like front loading story
lines and what we're going to hear from
our
colleagues in the media whether it's you
know uh warranted or not
i haven't brought this up to you guys
yet here in studio so i'm going to
unveil this with michael smith oh yeah
uh i i'm already seeing it i'm already
seeing it
i'm already feeling it i'm sensing it
that if the suns win it there's an
asterisk because lebron had a banged up
team
and giannis is banged up and trey young
is banged up
the clippers didn't have kawaii and
uh so on and so forth what do you think
of that
do you think we're going to see that
hear that from some corners of our
business
michael nobody from hopefully from
nobody respectable
credible i can't speak for twitter i
mean i'm sure somebody
somewhere i'm sensing it already though
you know what i mean like you know that
it's chris paul's moment but you know
so what you know what i mean i mean you
know lebron was less than
every year that's every year the
warriors got that
there are asterisks and now you may have
to say that word a bunch of time
there are asterisks assigned to every
championship based on one's
uh affiliation or allegiance or
preconceived notion
about that individual or that team the
war okay the warriors dynasty
has an asterisk affixed to it for one
reason or another
whether it's because they got kevin
durant or because
you know they beat lebron the first time
when co
kyrie and kevin love were hurt i mean if
you go down a list of pretty much every
champion if you really reach and i think
our guy tom aberstrom may have
even done an exercise like this if you
really wanted to reach
you could find an asterisk affixed to
everybody's championship
including lebron's last year so okay
chris paul
in his championship if the sons were to
win it there's an asterisk because
anthony davis got hurt well last year
you know
they try to say that lebron avoided the
clippers because
they couldn't hold on no three one lead
or what have you um
and you know even before that kawaii got
a championship
when durant and clay thompson were hurt
how many teams
is chris paul himself an asterisk for
because the warriors before they got to
the finals i'm not mistaken
we're trailing the rockets and then
chris paul hurt his hamstring i mean
it's it's mental gymnastics is
unnecessary
every championship involves a level of
luck and good fortune
it has always been a battle of attrition
it's just worse this year
so yes rich you will hear people try to
discredit the sun's championship
should they win it but those people are
silly and god that knows better to do
and probably just hate chris paul
who do you have on your show today what
do you got top of the hour here oh
we got uh baron davis is joining us
today uh our friend monica mcnutt is
joining us today
uh jason johnson msnbc making his
regular weekly appearance
uh you've been a good will from yahoo
coming through to apologize to chris
paul
because he had the nerve to try to
slander the point guard yesterday and i
tried to check him and then he went out
and
cooked the clippers in the second half
so yeah we got a jam-packed show
um and it's our last one before we take
more vacation because that's just what
we need coming off another week off i
got you michael smith you take care of
yourself best of holly and we'll see you
top of the hour
love y'all man appreciate it all right
thank you always love chatting with
michael smith
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here